[Music]
yes
it's that time again where we judge
other people's relationship
apparently my mom watched my lives video
thanks mom
she made fun of me for having too
swedish of a perspective so here we go
90 day fiance swedish perspective
edition
this is nikki and
mark i've seen a little bit of that
relationship
why does it say ryan
ryan penny edited this video
imagine if scythe started editing that
on
not happening side forget about it
all right so we got mark h 58
nikki 19. oh god oh
god oh no that's just
40 years reach age number
h nut number you all age old
you're hr oh god
all right it's already creepy let's keep
watching yeah it's
been two seconds it's the day that i
picked the camp at the airport
i can't really explain what's going
through me this is the happiest day of
my looks like a horror fight
doesn't it welcome home nikki mickey
my life i mean i'm crying but it's the
happiest day of my life
oh we're going to take a wild guess that
this man has already been married
[Music]
he's got a freaking pass i can make this
day special as i hope i can make every
day special
nicky being at the gate at the airport
just gives me goosebumps
i was married before uh to a woman from
the philippines on a k1 visa
and shortly after we moved here she
changed
radically shocking
never happened before unbelievable what
you're telling me the relationship is
different when you live together
radically and so i got
left raising four children in diapers
nice sorry like not even a second of
sympathy i'm sorry
that's tough ah jeez that sucks there
you go there's my empathy
[Music]
i think my family has worries about the
age difference and the fact that i could
be repeating my past i don't see why not
we've never seen this that this story
happened already
i'm sure they're gonna work out great
yeah true love let's go yeah but um
nikki and my ex-wife are extremely
different she's way younger
i'm sorry second i met nikki that
she was the right one for me
[Music]
yay
[Applause]
bruh she's 19 though
oh was that a little slight you notice
that slide side oh oh they cut before
oh hey yeah
[Applause]
when i see him holding roses negros and
chocolates like
whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
just wait till she sees the sign okay
she's gonna lose it
i'm excited the next 90 days will be
wonderful oh it's an open car
yeah see that there's an open car called
a convertible
very nice convertible bet you don't have
one of those in philippines
that you ride donkeys and horses and
philippines
oh it's not even hits it's the other car
there's traffic everywhere
here the streets are clean huh
nice house yes she lives in a nice area
so many times they bring people back
from these third world third world
countries
uh and it's america's worst
so funny putting fingerprints on my
windows
not loud it's not allowed no that was
one of the rules where my
children were really they never touched
never touch the window because
it's so i'm not allowed to touch the
window you don't touch the window
you don't touch the window oh because
you have to clean the bed
you're not in trouble hey do you want me
to be happy nicky did you nicki you're
messing with me
you're messing with my happiness
there's one of the rules nikki all right
it's just just a number
but you cannot touch the win i can't
wipe
it back no no no no we'll get you a
towel to wipe it okay
it's too serious i always told him that
mark why are you so
serious huh you're weird
i know i'm always weird
that's why i love you so much thank you
for that you're welcome for that
[Music]
think that as time goes on that i'm
going to see that
nikki isn't as well rounded maybe and
not
you know a little immature i'm hoping
that would she's my thing
what do you think she's
normal you're the weird one please
oh my god those issues
do you think you'll feel like you're at
home i don't know yet maybe
i don't know anybody here in america
it's really important to me that his
family and me
get along well oh it's tomorrow i'm
going to meet elise
my daughter elise is dragging her feet
how old is her daughter
to be cordial and i want you to be the
best of friends his daughter for the
last side
you you're not doing this all right
you're not sneaking what is it ryan
a video editor for 20 years i was a
single dad
that's why i really truly hope so he's
got us to say my daughter
and nikki get along
that's weird that's weird can you
imagine
your parents dating someone your age
ages number number
mark and i've been uh it's only been 30
30 days i'm confused
or maybe they're getting married right
away yeah that makes sense
because he wants me to decide rather
want kids before the 90 days over
but i don't know what i'm going to feel
after 5 years
10 years don't i think
you're 19 run run what's your name nikki
run do not let this man knock you up no
mark and i need a little space and the
only person i know is elise
his daughter but the last time we talk
we still feel
uncomfortable really awkward
you have to figure out what you have in
common i am somewhat filipino
there we go oh
[Music]
she is not happy all right she because
she's happy filipino then
i'm somewhat filipino there we go
oh this is great you're gonna feel a
little nervous but
i need someone to talk to she has no one
else to talk to how are you holding dave
how are you
i'm pretty good oh she is done
oh not even trying solid school oh
school's good
it's always good um we can go look at
some shops if you want yeah we can
okay
[Music]
oh attention's a cream
it's all mush shocked that nikki wanted
to hang out but i'm actually
hoping that since my dad's not around
i'll be able to see
like who she is and she'll be able to
talk to me more
do you think she'll call her mom she's
technically older than nikki
he's just number listen
yeah yeah it's just number but it's just
weird
yeah i do miss my friends
back in philippines but excited to spend
time with someone that is closer to my
age i guess i've been with mark
oh hi now that feels like perfect for
a beach wedding
this dress is really really gorgeous are
you having a beach wedding
they're not quite sure yet we're still
on
so weird it's so weird it hurts you feel
it does it pain you is it just painful
for me this
i want to know i find it interesting
what people cringe about
and other people don't it seems so
subjective sometimes
are you married i'm marrying a weird guy
she said that so honestly i'm marrying a
weird guy
that is the situation this is my mom
i mean he is weird yeah i love him
wow okay
i'm a little worried that nikki's bored
86 how did we get to 86 days
it was 56 a second ago so this morning
i'm surprising her with
something big oh god what is he gonna do
he got her a car
last night so what do you think damn
it's new it's like new why don't you why
don't you sit in there and see how it is
oh is it his car oh no
never tried driving a car before
i can't even learn driving in
philippines because the streets are very
not safe
you look pretty good in it thank you so
much but i need to learn how to drive
wait no you can drive me home i'm going
to drive you home now
yeah it's just around the corner no no
no no no no
first you have to put your seatbelt on
why is the brake right now i don't have
my
he's never driven a car started the
parking lot
isn't that a break so i guess you don't
have clutch in america it's easier isn't
it
you can't you can't do anything no if
i'm so nervous i might run this so fast
and we're going to bomb
you're not going to bomb you'll be fine
i think i can teach nikki
how to drive i taught my children how to
drive so i
i think i can do this put your foot on
the brake
push hard okay that's drive
okay and now you're just going to drive
right here oh god please don't crash
no no no no i'm going numb why don't i
have a registration plan okay
now make the turn you have to make the
turn
thank you for driving me home nikki oh
okay it wasn't fun okay
see now how hard was that how hard was
that
it was cool okay but where
nikki loved this car and i'm hoping
that'll be enough
to keep her happy because my future
depends on her happiness
when i sit in this car nikki it rolls my
clock back
25 years it's absolutely perfect you're
still too old for her
even with 25 years but that
that still makes him like what 32.
it's still weird
[Laughter]
it's so nice to see a man and up the
daughter from a poor
country he says he doesn't want more
kids proceeds to marry a child
i bought the same car for my ex-wife he
said that i had bought the same car
for my ex-wife oh
oh what a perfect timing too look at our
base wait
that's like how to ruin a present in two
seconds there you go
dlc the best man for her to get around
though because she liked the car
um but then you know she had problems
learning to get her uh
license and then of course she got
pregnant
it's painful but we're watching more i
i gotta do this man this is the 90 day
fiance
rewind oh yeah i wonder who edited this
nikki arranges mark's bookshelf
ruins his life nice
i wonder what kind of books he has
uh oh
those books have not even been open you
can tell
you can tell
nice she's helping out
i mean honestly depends how she
organizes that
if she organizes them by color throw her
out right at the spot
if she organized him chronologically
throw him out right at the spot
i get it
i never heard that that's hilarious
yes that's the real base way to organize
books big to small
imagine going to a library excuse me
do you have moby dick oh that's in the
big section
divorce books
oh she don't like the divorce books
oh god this is killing him look how
oh he wants he's like one of those
people you know fair fair enough
that seems to want to always emit like a
positive
uh energy like every day is great every
good day it's uplifting
which is fine but uh when you're in this
confrontational issue
situations you can tell it's just
killing him isn't it
oh god oh that's kind of sweet
i don't know why it's nice to see
the daughter help out around the house i
mean the wife sorry he's wearing someone
he's gonna have to raise yeah
and those are your divorce rates yeah
i'm hoping i wanted to read those again
but i'll still i'll still keep them all
right nikki and mark's not normal
relationship prompts awkward family
meeting there's nothing
awkward about this relationship so far
that's confusing
that's like the nicest way of saying
this is weird as hell
oh she said it oh it's weird when you
say it out loud
that's a bit forward to ask someone you
just met don't you think
huh
so
yeah in the future yeah it's got plenty
of time
what does he think is ages what
those are my decades of quality time
i'll be a fool to gamble my decades of
quality time
those are all the videos are they still
together
i'm watching a gossip channel now this
is what we're going to
welcome back to the uh gee i just want
to know are they still i'm you know i'm
googling it
are mark and nikki still together
90 days this smells like a weird
invasion of privacy i don't like this
40-year age difference mark doesn't have
any social media
her instagram hasn't been updated since
2013.
i give them the benefit doubt and assume
they're still together so we don't
know it hurts i need to know all right
well that was it for this
episode of tlc swedish perspective
hope you enjoyed mom that's wait a
minute you're saying what the
uh look at this graph
nineteen percent of you aren't
subscribed what are you doing
it's free see you guys tomorrow on the
new episode
[Music]
brofist